what is a big beat a big beat for me is
the pulse of a screenplay so it's like
the heartbeat and there are certain if
you want to get technical and call it
page count I try not to do that it's
very limiting if you say by by Page 20
this has to open and I think uh that can
be very limiting when you're trying to
teach it but it's uh the big beats for
me are the the driving force or the
signposts behind where your story is
going so as I mentioned the inciting
incident should be around page 10 to 15
roughly right um that if you can get it
on page six all power to you um but that
has a function in the script which is to
split the character's wants and needs to
be the explosive beginning of our story
this is what our story is going to be
about and this is the decision our
characters are going to have to make
right then you got the debate section
with Blake okay do I want to it's that
Hero's Journey do I want to accept this
is this really the way that I need to go
so we explore that through other
characters relationships the actions
that your main character will take to
try and reject the journey or accept the
journey then by the end of act one
another big beat this is where the
character is forced to make a decision
to go on the journey that we're going to
watch or they're pushed into it either
way there's no turning back there's
absolutely no road back they've got to
now tell the story um so adhering to
those big beats uh the midpoint Journey
once we get to the midpoint of a script
um that's an important part of a script
of a screenplay for me because it's
where the characters wants and needs
come really close they almost get to
understand what they need right while
still pursuing what they want but
something happens an event um a meat
Cube or however you want to put it um
something happens to push them even
further away from it getting what they
want and need uh so it twists your
character in a completely different
direction um and then you have you know
in between the midpoint and the First
Act you have a small you might have a
small minor defeat or a minor victory
for your main character same in between
the end back two and midpoint um this is
a very structured and Technical way of
doing it but I love it um and I think
it's relevant and then you get to the
end of your second act right through the
bad guys closes into your second act and
at the end of the second act your
character might get a version of what
they want but they've lost something
they lose something they may not get
what they need um but they might get a
version of what they want but there's
still something missing there's
something wrong and what they what they
still don't see is this thing they need
um and I think you know I develop this
with when I'm teaching uh I get my
students to watch films and I get them
to identify where these points are
happening in those films
um and uh and so that's what I mean by a
big beat is once I've developed my
character biographies and I kind of know
what the story is and I think I know the
ending I try to put you know that
doesn't mean it can't change depending
on what you find but I try to elevate
these sign posts as the start of my
outline okay here's what happens in the
exciting incident based on what my
character wants and needs that's the
explosive inciting incident then what's
going to happen at the end of act one
where they have to go on this journey
what what is that thing identify it
identify the midpoint identify the and
so I try as an exercise I try to get
them to identify that all the way to the
final confrontation scene or the taking
back of the loss at the end of act two
and then into do they get what they need
and want
um does a character have to get what
they need they may not do they have to
get what they want no they should get
one or the other sometimes they get both
you know um and I think you know if you
look at Whiplash for instance another
great film being a drummer and all um
you look at Miles teller's journey
through that with JK simmers a
tremendous film if you have not seen it
um but it's indicative of that you know
this guy wants to be the best drummer in
the world right that's what he wants
that's his super objective that and when
he meets JK is he accepted into the
class it's an inciting incident that's
like oh this is it what he what he needs
to understand is he's going to have to
sacrifice everything else but he doesn't
see it he meets this he meets this
really wonderful nice kind girl in the
cinema right during that
period and they agreed to a date right
that's that story that subplot and most
B plots are connected to a character's
need what are they need to understand
that they're not seeing the mere fact
that later on near the midpoint he says
to her in a restaurant you're going to
get in the way of me being the best
drummer ever pretty much we're breaking
up I don't want anything to do with you
they're that close to to actually
becoming a couple and he blows it all up
in service of this hollow want um and so
you can see that structure working you
know if you lay the template over it um
and that's what I mean by big beats
being really conscious that at certain
points in the film what draws us along
is a big change in something for the
character or their world that that is
connected to their wants and needs why
do you love outlining for me it's
writing the that's writing the story I
love to write the
story um I also love to rewrite outlines
I spend a long time rewriting it so so I
will go back to things like like my
character biography and have a look at
and I'll rewrite my character biography
right and I'll or I'll rewrite the
outline itself based on what I discover
because one of the you know one of the
elements of screenwriting is the setup
and payoff of certain things you set a
whole bunch of stuff up in the First Act
it's got to pay off by the third act or
we're going to get irritated so the idea
of discovering things along the way I
have to go back to the First Act of what
I've created so essentially when I'm
doing writing I don't necessarily do a
traditional treatment my outline just
seems to morph into a treatment so all
my outlines are be bullet points in
between the big beats so in between
those big beats are bullet points of
what's Happening why it's happening you
know if I hear dialogue I might put a
bit in um I won't write it I won't
format it but I'll have my charact if I
hear my character say something in
service of that beat I'll write that in
so it becomes this like worksheet that I
then keep rewriting and rewriting until
it becomes almost a treatment So
eventually in the bullet points I'll
start to put in Slug lines right and
then what's happening in that scene
who's in the scene what they might say
but not in a screenplay
format That's essential for me so that
when I get into the screenplay itself
I'm more focused on the formatting of
the screenplay you know and the
structure and the rewriting of
description and transitions between
scenes and how does that play you know
and what is this sequence so I'm then
plugging in the first draft it's like
I'm plugging the I I literally cut and
paste the entire outline
into the screenplay format and then I
just play with it that way and I format
it and then I rewrite it before it gets
you know before it would get to my
manager I've probably Rewritten it 20
times so the outline for me is that
Foundation to the story it's a
foundation and a place to discover the
character it's a place where I can be
literary where I can do swaths of
description if I want to you know I can
exercise my literary side knowing that
when it goes into the script I have to
cut it all which is never happy for me
but you know that's that's why an
outline is important I just have to know
those big beats and what's happening in
between so I can then really focus on
the structure and formatting of the
first draft has anyone try to talk you
out of so much structure and say all
this isn't necessary no never you've
never you've never I mean I've listened
to other people talk um and I think one
of the things of being a screenwriter is
you have to remain open you must remain
open to at least listening um the
process that I go through in writing
isn't just something I learned from one
person I learned by listening to oh
that's you know the idea of of taking a
character biography and doing an
interview rather than just writing the
biography I didn't know that straight
away it's something that I found a
writer doing when I was working at
screen gems um and then at worldwide
actually worldwide Acquisitions in
screen gems is some you know the
interview process was a way to get into
my character by just having these set of
questions um and so I've taken little
bits that help me along the way um but
no one will ever convince me of you know
not having structure in fact you know
one of my one of my favorite uh podcasts
is is script notes with John August and
Craig Mason who are just tremendously
gifted writers and Industry
mentors um I I could listen to them and
have listened to them pretty much since
they started um Craig doesn't love film
schools doesn't necessarily believe in
film schools but he does there is a
tremendous episode of this um called how
to write a movie if you can find it I
forget that's 400 and something if you
get a chance to go to script notes and
look for that it's called how to write a
movie John August wasn't on and so Craig
took the reins and it I've got the
transcript the transcript is phenomenal
and he put it into like 45 minutes this
is how you write a movie and it's a
little anti-st structuralist but the way
he came from character and the way he
talked about developing a story is just
it's worth a listen because it's just
tremendous and I don't agree with
everything he says I needed a film
school because I didn't have a grounding
in film or TV I came from the theater
which is a very different medium and I
needed somewhere where I could immerse
myself for me film school was the right
fit um and I wasn't 18 I was 34 so I had
already had some career in something
else so um but uh but no one is ever
going to talk me out of structure one
I've seen it I've seen it fix films too
many
times um I've seen it fix screenplays
and develop screenplays from an idea
into an amazing film and no one's going
to convince me not to use structure am I
completely closing on the door closing
the door on people who don't use
structure no um I don't think you can
look at well I don't think you can look
at Charlie Kaufman's work too much and
see a whole lot of adherence to
traditional structure um it does exist
but I guarantee he knows it have you had
the pleasure of meeting either Craig or
John um I have not um uh not personally
um I've listened to their master classes
uh um we I think we had John up at AFI
when I was there like just to give a
talk
um but uh I've not necessarily met him
personally um and so I haven't met Craig
at
all